. So we had another weekend as often happens,
uh, every week. And what that means in practice
is that our president has again unleashed
another furious tweetstorm riddled with spelling
and grammar errors and random capitalization
of words. And the topic this time was Supreme
Court justice. Brett Kavanaugh. There are
new sexual assault allegations against Brett
Kavanaugh. Despite having been told during
the confirmation hearings of Brett Cavanaugh
that the FBI looked into all of the allegations
into Brett Kavanaugh.
Uh, not surprising, not shocking. More allegations
have surfaced, including ones that the FBI
did not look into during his confirmation
hearings. And the, the particulars of the
latest allegation are that Cavenaugh exposed
his most intimate of areas use your imagination,
um, to a female Yale classmate and the others
subsequently pushed the hands of the classmate
into Cavanagh's most intimate of areas. Nothing
shocking about this. Nothing surprising. This
seems to just be who Brett Kavanaugh is. It
became very, very clear of course, no particular
reason now to be concocting this, uh, some
of the normal Twitter hangers on suggesting
that it's because we are now 14 months from
an alley, from an election that now some bogus
allegation against an already confirmed Supreme
Court justice who is almost impossible to
remove, uh, make sense for political reasons,
which I mean, if you're going to concoct something,
concoct something that actually has a shot
at doing some damage to the person involved,
Donald Trump flying off the handle as a result,
immediately suggesting that Cavenaugh super
listened to this one, he should sue for liable.
Now why am I pointing at pronouncing it liable?
Because that's how Trump's spelled it. L I
a. B. L, e, I guess. Meaning of course, Lib
e l, libel. A published false statement damaging
to a person's reputation. Trump concocting
a bizarre conspiratorial series of tweets.
First tweeting, Brett Kavanaugh should start
suing people for liable or the Justice Department
should come to his rescue, which by the way,
the Justice Department coming to his rescue
is an extremely authoritarian suggestion.
Trump going on. The lies being told about
him are unbelievable false accusations without
recrimination. When does it stop? They are
trying to influence his opinions. Can't let
that happen. Eventually Trump deleted it and
re posted it with the corrected spelling of
a libel and then kept going with more. Quote,
can't let Brett Kavanaugh radical left Democrat
liberal plus opinions. Each one of those words
capitalized. Why? We don't know based on threats
of capitol.
I impeaching him over made up stories, sound
familiar, false allegations and lies. This
is the game they play. Fake and corrupt news
is working overtime. Hashtag protect Kavanaugh.
I the these are the, these are the rantings
of the equivalent of someone again who's yelling
at you while they urinate on the subway tracks,
uh, on Canal Street. While you wait for the
six train. I'll do one more tweet, not the
entire list of tweets because it's quite frankly,
there's too much to keep up with Trump tweeting.
I am fighting the fake corrupt news, the deep
state, the Democrats and the few remaining
Republicans in name only rhinos who are on
mouth to mouth resuscitation with the help
of some truly great Republicans and others.
We are winning Big 150th federal judge this
week. Now the last thing Trump mentions there,
150 federal judges, uh, Trump's right about
this. I've talked about this before.
Supreme Court selections get a lot of attention.
Federal judgeships much less so, and Donald
Trump is actually winning really big with
those federal judgeship selections. It gets
very little attention. It has a huge impact
and it has a huge impact for a very long time
and most cases never make it to the supreme
court. A lot of the important precedent in
this country is ultimately decided by federal
judges, many of which have now been appointed
by Donald Trump. I think we've, we found that
about 25% of current federal and Superior
Court, I forget the categorizations, have
been selected by Trump and just two years.
And this has a massive, massive impact. Now
as far as the subject matter. The idea of
a liable suits against accusers of Kavanaugh.
Consider for a second that there have been,
what, 15, 16, 1920 women who have accused
Donald Trump of anything ranging from a, uh,
verbal sexual harassment all the way up to
an including rape.
Donald Trump has not filed a single libel
lawsuit. I wonder why that is. If anybody
who is falsely accused of sexual assault deserves
to be, have to have a libel lawsuit filed
against them, and it would be something in
which one could prevail. Why hasn't Donald
Trump filed a single libel lawsuit against
all of his accusers? And of course, there
will not be any libel lawsuits, uh, by Brett
Kavanaugh against these accusers either. And
I think we all know why that is. Going back
once again to the idea from Donald Trump's
tweets that he's fighting the fake corrupt
media. This is the last thing I want to touch
on. Trump's net fighting the fake corrupt
media, the fake corrupt news media as Trump
calls it. Or I just call it corporate media.
They are in on the game. And what I mean by
that is that you have some incorporate media
that just will defend Trump endlessly or almost
endlessly like Fox News.
Others take a more critical editorial perspective.
MSNBC, others play the enlightened watchdogs
with bipartisan panels like CNN, but they're
all participating in the game. They create
and suck out all the ratings that they can
from the distraction stories and narratives
that Donald Trump creates. And then when the
time is up, they just move on to the next
thing. Never really closing the book on the
impact of each of these narratives. And uh,
Trump is simply wrong because they are actually
working with him. The fight is the public
spin on it. But the reality is that corporate
media have been in with Trump, including the
billions and free publicity that they gave
him from the time he started his campaign.
That is backwards. Trump has that backwards.
And again, Trump is completely erratic and
unhinged every single weekend on Twitter.